you know we've talked about it before on
the podcast where I think that there's a
real problem with cops arresting
criminals and not that they shouldn't
but there's a real problem that it
becomes a game like you're trying to win
you're trying to catch people for doing
things and you're trying to lock them up
and when you're trying to win because
that is a win you know if you get
someone you lock them up you arrest them
you catch them they get convicted they
go up River I sent them up River I win
and that is an absolute it's there's a
there's a certain amount of but what
we've sort of developed all throughout
high school years and junior high school
and whatever kids play sports mm-hmm and
we develop this winning mentality the
game is to be won you know whether it's
a game of pool or lawn darts or [ __ ]
basketball people are always trying to
win and when you have people that are
raised in some of the most intense
moments of their life especially if
you've been involved in competitive
sports like if you've been on a
championship baseball team or something
like that mm-hmm you go from that and
your your next experiences in life or
being a police officer
you're gonna definitely take that sports
mindset and apply it to chasing down
criminals and it could be good and it
can be bad but the problem is when
people start justifying certain things
like planting evidence and doing things
along those lines in order to get a
conviction because they want to win
that's when [ __ ] gets really really
scary because someone has incredible
amount of power and if someone is doing
something to make you look more guilty
just so that they can win mm-hmm that's
scary yeah
I [ __ ] hate you I said I [ __ ] hate
you you stupid little bastard
walking along next to a proper police
officer you track a little community
support customer doesn't look you can
just flip him well oh yeah flipping you
do well too choosy words carefully
swearing at a real police officer is not
a very good idea is it Sonny Boy now
then excuse me listen you shouldn't
really be you hell do you think you're
doing plays quite in his back on the
pavements you've stay out of this
who told you you could grab his arm what
what do you think that is police
brutality where we all look that's not
police brutality that's just community
support brutality a normal reality do
you want to see some police brutality
police brutality something you would
know nothing about in your official
capacity as just some guy on your way
you know I love what do you see on TV
you know they I love the way they you
know they put the chokehold on the guy
they beat him with the baton they put
the handcuffs on but when they put him
in the backseat there was put the hand
on the head you don't want to hit your
head on that metal
[Applause]
don't hurt your head there your face is
all swollen from the beam but that metal
edge that really smart oh I you know
this tough job being a cop with that I
think of the different cop jobs the
chalk outline guy that seems like one of
the better cop job the crooks are gone
already you know there's much danger I
don't know if these are guys that wear
some sketch artist couldn't quite handle
it you know you think if we left the guy
lying there you might be able to just
trace around them could you do that you
know Plus how does it even help them you
know I don't understand Oh his horn was
like that when he hit the pay where they
kill it must be Jim when I was a kid I
got love thank God I stole triple beam
balances for my science class I sold him
to drug dealers for pot I was in eighth
grade I was like 12 years old all right
I stole like 20 of them cuz I got
somehow I figured out how to get into
this science
anyways I got caught and they just knew
I did it and I just kept saying no I
didn't know I kept saying I didn't I
don't even know what you're talking now
I don't even do drugs I don't smoke pot
I just kept saying it in the and I just
wore them down you ever watch it I
didn't say friends what we can't really
carry bonds getting ready to go to court
for lying about sometimes you saying
that no one can prove all he's got to do
is keep denying no but it's different
cause he's black people deny anything
it's the opposite for blacks all right I
forgot to play the opposite when they
deny something you go my Jesus what a
liar no it's exactly why do we have to
premise this whole thing all white
people have to do right is it not and
eventually people go oh come on give me
the benefit of the day black people have
to confess or else it's just gonna get
hot
if you watch any of those shows we have
an app to change the entire system yeah
I love those shows I love the crime
shows on A&E where they show the
confessions right and they bring people
in and a lot of times the people that
just stick to the denial it goes into
the cold-case files and maybe they get
him 20 years later yeah but it's the
people that are sitting there and say
come on now look we got this this this
and they never really have anything but
it goes all right yeah okay I was in the
car when he was shot I was and then
before you know the guys like I shot the
man I killed him I think a problem
solved crime solved just deny it but the
more you say - you have to just say no
no I know what it is you know no the
more you talk they're gonna get you cops
I gotta I was with this lady one time
that you pay to give you back rubs okay
and as soon as we're done I actually
just put my sneaker on knock knock knock
cops right at the door and they came in
and they they had me they took me on the
curb
they just started going come on man what
was going on they will you just get will
you just get a baby needs the only
reason they're asking is because they
need you to say yes I just kept going
nope no no no no but they would get me
too like buddy-buddy like yeah well I
mean one I mean we were I was like no no
and they finally were like look he's not
saying it that would you let me go they
were pesto that really that really is
the difference between life for whites
and blacks if you're white and you kill
somebody on television as long as you
just keep denying it you're gonna get
out of it yeah if you're black and you
were at home sleeping and someone 4,000
miles away got killed and they ask you
if you did it you better just say
unless monk is around advice don't take
[ __ ] from anybody
question mark bill sometimes you and
your podcast with go [ __ ] yourselves and
don't take [ __ ] from anyone well let me
tell you my story back in November a cop
pulled me over roughed me up was a huge
[ __ ] and wrote up every rinky-dink
e-ticket he could not okay now wait a
minute what happened you were just
driving down the street and this guy
just pulled you over I need a little bit
of the backstory here was this guy did
you know did he get into a big fight
with his wife and then took it out on
you or we did you say something wise to
the guy and he said all right I'm not in
the [ __ ] mood
anyways let's see if we can figure it
out here at the end of the altercation I
shook his hand look him straight in the
eyes and gave him that look that says I
will see you in court [ __ ] I showed
up in court this Monday to defend myself
my plan was to stand before that [ __ ]
and having him explain his actions to me
in a court of law yeah dude this ain't
gonna work out unless he had a witness I
wanted to ask him even then that doesn't
work out I wanted to ask him if twisting
my arms so much that I couldn't use it
for a few days was justified I wanted to
ask him why he decided that me 5/6 175
pounds was a threat to him six foot two
six foot three 250 that he need to hit
me from behind dude call me an [ __ ]
but I'm not a hundred percent buying
this story because you didn't say what
happened before this this guy just did
this is this guy like the [ __ ] worst
cop ever I don't know here we go I
wanted to I wanted to know why he needed
to demean me while I was handcuffed in
the back of the paddy wagon I then
wanted to ask him how many excessive
force complaints he had against him the
answer is four of [ __ ] so I'm wrong here
I wanted to ask him how his marriage
ended his ex-wife has a restraining
order against him for domestic violence
all right I tap out you're right you're
right sorry I wanted to ask him what
part of protect and serve did he not
understand I wanted to end the
questioning with him explaining how he
got caught on a cell phone camera a cell
a motorist you can look up the video on
YouTube under Milwaukee police Lambo
driver la MBO driver here's what sucks
in Milwaukee if the cop that wrote you
the ticket this doesn't show up in court
your case is dismissed and you don't
have to pay anything
well guess guess why I told you that the
piece of [ __ ] didn't show up in court
ah that's awful I need advice do I let
this all be water on the bridge or do I
take this [ __ ] down I really want
justice but I don't want to be beaten by
other cops what should I do
well I think you just shed some light
Milwaukee police Lambo driver all my
listeners will probably look up and
watch that now this guy sounds like a
dangerous guy look you know this is what
I would do if I was gonna try to take
this dude down what I would do is you
know what the local news loves doing now
they love showing like YouTube videos
and they love talking about Twitter and
all that type of stuff because they're
desperately trying to get the kids and
people because they're losing all this
viewership to to the Internet so the
fact that you you have this
controversial thing you have this [ __ ]
up law and you have a youtube video of
this guy that makes that's like one of
those perfect little pieces you know
coming up next Milwaukee police officer
a little out of line check out the
YouTube video that everybody's been
talking about all the alerta' you mean
you can go that way but yeah I mean
you're taking a you're definitely going
to take a [ __ ] risk you know so you
know Rodney King died this week and that
brought up that whole video and all that
type of [ __ ] and I know you know the guy
just pulled over that's what you're
supposed to do I know I mean look who's
kidding no Ronnie King was gonna get
beat down no matter what I mean if
you've run from the [ __ ] cops I don't
give a [ __ ] who you are you got to get
beat down but if you get back up you
charge them a couple times
abso-fucking-lutely but you know the
got to be a way to take a guy down
without giving them 12 [ __ ] skull
fractures you know what I'm saying it's
if I don't know it's a it's it's it's
it's a [ __ ] thankless job
and then it's a really dangerous job if
the wrong kind of person gets uh gets
the job why did my phone just go off